So in a sense, C++ and Java and Python and C sharp, they're all really the same language-ish. They're all descended from Algoll, right? But then something like Lisp or Smalltalk or Prologue, they are different. They are qualitatively different. They're different families. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 234 recorded on May 13th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my cohost Ben, we recap C++ now 2025. How's it going? We're back. All right. Yeah, it's going pretty well.
从某种意义上说，C++、Java、Python 和 C# 其实都算是同一种语言。它们都源自 Algol，对吧？但像 Lisp、Smalltalk 或 Prolog 这样的语言则不同。它们在本质上是不同的。它们属于不同的家族。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 234 期，录制于 2025 年 5 月 13 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起回顾 2025 年的 C++ Now 大会。最近怎么样？我们回来了。好的，是的，一切都挺好的。
Yeah, what is it? It's May 13th or halfway through May, which is I don't know what puts that percentage through the summer. Is it officially summertime now? I actually don't know. It might be spring still. It's probably still spring. You know, people say the first day of spring is the spring equinox.
是啊，现在是什么时候？5 月 13 日，五月过半了，我不知道这算过了夏季的百分之多少。现在正式进入夏天了吗？我其实不知道。可能还是春天。大概还是春天吧。你知道，人们常说春天的第一天是春分。
To me that's not really the first day of spring, but... I see. I mean, it depends on where you are in the world, I guess. We don't have much spring in Toronto. It's just cold, then there's a couple weeks, and then it's summer. And then sometimes it's winter for a day or two, like as a practical joke that the weather gods play on us. Fake spring?
对我来说那并不是真正的春天开始，但是……我明白了。我的意思是，这取决于你身处世界何地。多伦多的春天很短。天气很冷，然后暖和几周，接着就是夏天了。有时还会像天气之神跟我们开玩笑一样，突然又冷回冬天一两天。虚假的春天？
I think you pay extra attention to spring considering how short it might be. I guess. I guess. I'm just happy that it's like 20 plus degrees ish in Celsius, which is it's getting, it feels like it's summertime, at least this weekend. It was very, very nice. Yeah. Same in Denver.
考虑到春天可能很短，我想你会格外关注它。我想是吧。我只是很高兴气温能达到 20 多摄氏度，感觉就像夏天一样，至少这个周末是这样。天气非常好。是的，丹佛也一样。
In fact, it's been hotter than that even it's been mid 20s I think today it's yeah right now it's 25 Celsius so yeah into the low 80s it's been what is it in it's only 13 degrees right now but that's because I think it's about the weather people are saying it's about to rain or they actually say it's raining right now, which I can tell you is false But hey, it's hard to get the weather right even in the moment, I guess Anyways you were recently at one of the I guess not biggest Decidedly not biggest but but for my money Probably the best the most enjoyable
事实上，甚至比那还要热，我想今天气温在 25 摄氏度左右，也就是华氏 80 多度。现在只有 13 度，但我认为这是因为天气预报说快要下雨了，或者他们说现在正在下雨，但我可以告诉你那是假的。不过嘿，即使是当下，也很难准确预测天气。总之，你最近参加了……我想说不是规模最大的，绝对不是最大的，但就我个人而言，可能是最好、最令人享受的……
C++ conference that C++ now, of course in Aspen in Aspen. Yes up in the mountains where the air is thinner Yeah, Aspen's what just over 8,000 feet I think How is how is that? Yeah, I wasn't there but you were you were speaking It was really good You know as it always is, you know, this year the attendance was down a bit, you know distinct lack of the usual a Lot of the usual Europeans did not attend and also some Canadians Tony was not there Notable by his absence, but having said that there were lots of good talks
C++ 大会，当然就是 C++ Now，在阿斯彭。在阿斯彭。是的，在空气稀薄的山上。阿斯彭海拔大概 8000 英尺多一点吧？感觉如何？是的，我没去，但你去了，你还在那儿做了演讲。真的很棒，一如既往。你知道，今年参会人数有所下降，很多常来的欧洲人没能参加，还有一些加拿大人也没来。Tony 没去，他的缺席很引人注目，但话虽如此，还是有很多精彩的演讲。
There were a lot there were still also lots of good folks who did make it. And it was fun. There were some Canadians, Braydon was there. And so was Rob Lahey. Technically, I mean, Rob's Canadian, but he's like, how would you describe, I mean, we had Rob on the podcast, one of my favorite interviews ever.
还是有很多优秀的人参加了。这很有趣。有一些加拿大人，Braydon 去了。Rob Lahey 也去了。严格来说，Rob 是加拿大人，但你会怎么形容他呢？我们曾邀请 Rob 上过播客，那是我最喜欢的采访之一。
We were walking through Venice, post wine and much seafood. And he was one of the most articulate while walking posts, wine interviews. I mean, I guess we've only really done it with him, but I couldn't. I couldn't believe how composed he stayed. And but he lives, unless if he's moved since I last spoke to him, he lives in New York.
我们当时走在威尼斯，喝了点酒，吃了很多海鲜。在喝了酒之后，他依然是我采访过最能言善辩的人之一。我的意思是，我想我们只采访过他一次，但我无法相信他能保持得那么镇定。而且，除非他最近搬家了，否则他应该住在纽约。
So he's a, I'd almost consider him half Canadian, half New Yorker at this point. Well, he gave a talk anyway about, let me find the exact title, Extending Stead Execution was his title. So he talked about implementing custom algorithms with senders and receivers. And as is typical for his talks, he always gives a very polished talk. I think he's taken classes in public speaking in the past.
所以此时此刻，我几乎认为他一半是加拿大人，一半是纽约人。无论如何，他做了一个演讲，让我找找确切的标题，他的标题是《扩展 Stead 执行》。所以他谈到了用发送者（senders）和接收者（receivers）实现自定义算法。正如他演讲的典型风格，他总是准备得非常充分。我想他过去可能上过公共演讲课。
Yeah. And his talks are very polished and especially this one, because he showed a lot of C++ code. It was very dense. So it's the kind of talk I'm going to want to go back and watch again on YouTube. But it was it was a great talk to sit in and I I managed to follow most of it at the time. But as you know, with these things, you know, you need to go back and sort of reinforce. You know, you need to go back and sort of reinforce. Yeah, no, definitely. And I guess we should we should mention this now for the listeners that are going to definitely be curious about this.
是的。他的演讲非常精炼，尤其是这次，因为他展示了大量的 C++ 代码。内容非常密集。所以这是那种我想回到 YouTube 上再看一遍的演讲。但坐在现场听感觉很棒，我当时设法跟上了大部分内容。但正如你所知，对于这些内容，你需要回去复习巩固一下。是的，绝对是。我想我们现在应该告诉听众，他们肯定会对此感到好奇。
Do we know because it's changed from years past how these videos get released. It used to be they kind of came out super quickly. I saw on Reddit now that there's like a if you're very eager, I think you can pay some money to get access ahead of time and then they're gonna slow I don't actually know the full details. Do you know well, so I don't know I Don't really know what timeline they'll be coming out on But but yes If you if you went to the conference you do get the early access Or you can buy the early access as several conferences are doing now i think i read somewhere that the first videos will be out.
我们知道视频发布方式与往年不同了吗？过去它们发布得非常快。我在 Reddit 上看到，如果你非常急切，我想你可以付点钱提前观看，然后他们会慢慢……我其实不知道全部细节。你知道吗？好吧，我确实不知道它们发布的具体时间表。但是的，如果你参加了会议，你确实可以获得提前访问权限，或者像现在许多会议所做的那样，你可以购买提前访问权限。我想我在某处读到第一批视频会在……
About a month after the conference so that will put it at the end of may beginning of june. And I expect, although I'm not sure, the keynotes might be out before then, or certainly the keynotes are usually among the first to be released. Yes. Yeah. Okay. Well, so as I always do, I will link the talks in the show notes of either the website or the podcast app, but they will usually be unlinked for the first several months. Oh, that's right.
会议结束后大约一个月发布，所以那应该是在五月底或六月初。我预计，虽然我不确定，但主题演讲可能会在那之前发布，或者至少主题演讲通常是第一批发布的。是的。好的。好吧，正如我一贯的做法，我会把演讲链接放在网站或播客应用的节目说明中，但它们通常在最初的几个月里是未公开的。哦，原来如此。
They're unlisted on YouTube. Yeah. Yeah. Well, not unlisted, like, but it'll just be the text of the link that will be there in the future. Oh, I see what you mean. And so I will anytime like I peruse the C++ subreddit and they have those videos that have been released.
它们在 YouTube 上是不公开的。是的。好吧，不是不公开，但未来那里只会显示链接文本。哦，我明白你的意思了。所以每当我浏览 C++ 的 Reddit 版块，看到那些已经发布的视频时……
So whenever I notice that there's a talk that comes out, I will retroactively go back and it's better to check the website. I don't usually go back to the podcast episodes because that's more work than it's worth. But anyways, you can check back on the website show notes for when these talks do come out. Right. But they will be. So if we're talking about a talk, you might not be able to watch it today. But if you're listening to this, you know, months in the future, so not May of 2025, it's probably already out online. So you can go check out Rob's talk and any of the other talks we're about to talk about, including yours. Yeah, yeah. So there were three keynotes. Sean gave the first.
每当我注意到有演讲视频发布，我就会回过头去更新，最好是查看网站。我通常不会回到播客剧集里去更新，因为那太麻烦了。但无论如何，当这些演讲发布时，你可以查看网站的节目说明。对。但它们会发布的。所以如果我们谈论某个演讲，你今天可能还看不了。但如果你是在几个月后听这个节目，也就是 2025 年 5 月之后，它可能已经在网上发布了。所以你可以去看看 Rob 的演讲以及我们要谈论的其他任何演讲，包括你自己的。是的，是的。所以有三场主题演讲。Sean 做了第一场。
I saw that. How was that? You know, it was good. It was really good. Sean will forgive me for saying this, but I'm in the same boat, but sometimes I feel like some of us have already given the most impactful talk we're going to give, you know, in terms of the most, you know, like see, it's hard to live up to C++ seasoning, given the impact that had. But it was a great keynote. It was called Are We There Yet?
我看到了。怎么样？你知道，很棒。真的很好。Sean 会原谅我这么说，但我也有同感，有时我觉得我们中的一些人已经做出了我们能做出的最具影响力的演讲，你知道，就影响力而言，很难超越《C++ Seasoning》。但那是一场很棒的主题演讲。标题是《我们到了吗？》。
It was a follow-up to his original keynote from C++ Now, the first one I think. Yeah, I saw in the, I think, description of the keynote it said it was a follow-up to BoostCon 2007, which I didn't even realize it went back that far. Maybe I'm misremembering. It was 2000. To 2007, yes. A possible future of software development. That was Sean's keynote in 2007. I wonder if that talk, because I'm not sure if they go back that far before C++ Now. I know some of the BoostCon talks are online, but I would be surprised if that is even available. Yeah, it was very sketchy before about 2014, 2015. That's about as far back as videos go. And even back in those days, some of them were before video sponsors.
这是他最初在 C++ Now 上的主题演讲的后续，我想是第一场。是的，我在主题演讲的描述中看到它说是 BoostCon 2007 的后续，我甚至没意识到它追溯到那么久以前。也许我记错了。是 2000 年。到 2007 年，是的。《软件开发的可能未来》。那是 Sean 2007 年的主题演讲。我不知道那个演讲，因为我不确定在 C++ Now 之前他们是否追溯到那么久远。我知道一些 BoostCon 的演讲在网上，但如果那个也能找到，我会很惊讶。是的，在 2014、2015 年之前，视频资料非常少。那是视频资料能追溯到的最远时间。即使在那些日子里，有些演讲甚至没有视频赞助。
Yeah, I was actually just, was it a week ago or two weeks ago? I can't remember how I found my way down the rabbit hole, but I ended up trying to watch a couple of Bartosz Maluski's really old C++ Now videos, but like it's like a camera recorder stood up and so depending on the year it's like the light wash you can barely make out what's on the screen and all you see is the shadowy figure with you know Bartosz's crazy haircut. Anyways not very watchable is the point so yeah anyways so a good talk but I mean like you said C++ seasoning
是的，我其实就在……是一周前还是两周前？我不记得我是怎么掉进这个兔子洞的，但我最终试图观看 Bartosz Maluski 的一些非常古老的 C++ Now 视频，但就像是一个摄像机架在那里，所以根据年份不同，光线很晃，你几乎看不清屏幕上的内容，你只能看到一个模糊的身影，还有 Bartosz 那疯狂的发型。总之，重点是没法看，所以是的，总之，演讲很棒，但就像你说的，《C++ Seasoning》……
hard to hard to live up to. Yeah. And I don't think I'll ever live up to, you know, context for all the things again. You never know. You got you got a few decades ahead of you. So yeah, so that was great. So Sean's keynote, we started off with Lisa had the midweek keynote, Lisa Lippincott. And that was a really great talk. I didn't actually realize that was a keynote because the title of it made it seem like it was a...
很难超越。是的。而且我不认为我能再次超越《Context for all the things》。你永远不知道。你还有几十年的时间呢。所以是的，那很棒。所以 Sean 的主题演讲之后，Lisa Lippincott 做了周中的主题演讲。那是一场非常棒的演讲。我其实没意识到那是主题演讲，因为标题听起来像是……
What was the title? Balancing the Books. I thought that was like a agenda item similar to the library of the week. We need to take a look at the finances. No, no. It was Lisa's midweek keynote and she talked about double entry bookkeeping across the function call interface. And it was a really interesting talk and I thought very easy to follow. Some of Lisa's talks get quite mathematical and although people might think I'm good at maths I don't have formal math training beyond high school.
标题是什么？《平衡账目》（Balancing the Books）。我以为那是一个议程项目，类似于“每周库”。我们需要看看财务状况。不，不。那是 Lisa 的周中主题演讲，她谈到了跨函数调用接口的复式记账法。这是一个非常有趣的演讲，我觉得很容易跟上。Lisa 的一些演讲变得相当数学化，虽然人们可能认为我擅长数学，但我没有高中以上的正规数学训练。
So I follow and keep up where I can. But anyway, balancing the books was great. It was she was talking about yeah so double entry bookkeeping of the contract of the rights given to the callee by the caller and the duties also imposed upon the caller by the callee. Right and so she presented a way of where both sides can hence double entry both sides can keep a record of credits and debits in the rights and duties and it gets to something like well it gets to something like borrow checking you know Well, it gets to something like borrow checking, you know, and it gets to a form of safety, we might say. But I'm really not doing it a good service there.
所以我尽可能地跟上。但无论如何，《平衡账目》很棒。她谈到了……是的，关于调用者赋予被调用者的权利以及被调用者强加给调用者的义务的复式记账。对，所以她提出了一种方式，双方都可以——因此是复式——双方都可以记录权利和义务的借方和贷方，这有点像……好吧，这有点像借用检查（borrow checking），你知道……好吧，这有点像借用检查，你知道，这是一种安全形式，我们可以这么说。但我并没有很好地解释它。
You should watch the keynote when it comes out. I was going to say, this sounds like a talk that you need to watch in order to fully grasp the ideas she's putting forward. Yeah, yeah. Some really interesting ideas in that one. And then the final keynote was Jeff Garland's keynote where it was, Generic Programming Considered Harmful. Now, I'm not a fan of the title because I'm not a fan of cliches in titles these days.
你应该在视频发布后观看那场主题演讲。我正想说，这听起来像是一个你需要观看才能完全掌握她所提出想法的演讲。是的，是的。那场演讲里有一些非常有趣的想法。最后一场主题演讲是 Jeff Garland 的，标题是《泛型编程被认为是有害的》。现在，我不是这个标题的粉丝，因为我最近不喜欢标题里的陈词滥调。
But the talk was great. I thought the talk was really, really, really good. Is it advocating for what the title says or is it the opposite? Because a lot of times it's click bait and then they would bait and switch. Quite the opposite. Jeff is very heavily into generic programming. He's one of its great practitioners over the years in terms of boost libraries and other things.
但演讲很棒。我觉得演讲真的、真的、真的很好。它是支持标题所说的，还是相反？因为很多时候这是点击诱饵，然后他们会玩“挂羊头卖狗肉”的把戏。恰恰相反。Jeff 非常热衷于泛型编程。多年来，他在 Boost 库和其他方面是泛型编程的伟大实践者之一。
So the title was really asking the question which the talk answers as, and the answer is no, I think. I see. Okay, so another one to put on the list. And there was a, I mean, a ton of other talks, some that mentioned generic programming, yours as well. And I noticed that there was, I think four different talks, or maybe only three, that there was a couple talks that
所以这个标题实际上是在问一个问题，演讲给出了答案，我想答案是否定的。我明白了。好的，所以这是另一个要加入列表的演讲。还有，我的意思是，还有很多其他演讲，有些提到了泛型编程，也包括你的。我注意到有……我想有四个不同的演讲，或者可能只有三个，有几个演讲……
mentioned declarative something. Yeah, yeah. So there was, I think three. Yeah. Well, so and they were quite, they were quite, they turned out to be quite different talks. So one was declarative refactoring for the masses. That was Andy Soffer's talk. Andy is an engineer at Bronto Source and that he has that company with Matt Kulukundis and his talk was about their tool that refactors, I think, C, but maybe also C++ into Rust.
提到了声明式（declarative）什么的。是的，是的。所以我想有三个。好吧，它们变得相当不同。一个是《面向大众的声明式重构》。那是 Andy Soffer 的演讲。Andy 是 Bronto Source 的一名工程师，他和 Matt Kulukundis 一起经营那家公司，他的演讲是关于他们的工具，该工具可以将 C，也许还有 C++ 重构为 Rust。
Oh, wow. I sadly didn't attend Andy's talk because it was in a time slot where I had to do something else. Then the other declarative talk was Richard Powell's talk, techniques for declarative programming in C++. And that was a really good talk for my money. That was, although again, it was in a time slot where I wanted to watch all of the talks in the time slot.
哦，哇。我很遗憾没能参加 Andy 的演讲，因为它在另一个时间段，我不得不做别的事情。另一个声明式演讲是 Richard Powell 的《C++ 中声明式编程的技术》。就我个人而言，那是一场非常棒的演讲。虽然同样，它也在一个我想看所有演讲的时间段里。
The sign of a good conference. But what was good about Richard's talk, I thought, was that he successfully did what I try and sometimes succeed in doing, but more often fail. He took kind of more everyday C++, so he wasn't talking about super template metaprogramming, like heavy stuff. He was talking about using a WX widgets framework in C++ and just writing applications and showing how to refactor the code to make it more declarative in the series of steps.
这是好会议的标志。但 Richard 演讲的好处在于，我认为他成功地做到了我有时尝试并偶尔成功，但更多时候失败的事情。他采用了更日常的 C++，所以他谈论的不是超级模板元编程那种重型内容。他谈论的是在 C++ 中使用 WX Widgets 框架，编写应用程序，并展示如何通过一系列步骤重构代码以使其更具声明性。
I thought it was a really nice talk, really some good learnings from that. Because as much as we try to program, well, I guess I shouldn't say that. I do do declarative programming and I do do generic programming as much as I can. But I also have to do object-oriented programming and I have to do structured programming and imperative programming as well. It's not all one way. We have to synthesize them all together. Because at the end of the day, at the bottom of everything, it's all imperative. And sometimes imperative is the right choice. It's like Stepanov in his efficient programming with components A9 series, which I'm now working through after having finished from mathematics
我觉得那是一场非常好的演讲，从中获得了一些很好的经验。因为尽管我们努力编程，好吧，我不该这么说。我确实在做声明式编程，也尽可能多地做泛型编程。但我也必须做面向对象编程，也必须做结构化编程和命令式编程。并非只有一种方式。我们必须将它们全部综合起来。因为归根结底，在一切的最底层，它都是命令式的。有时命令式是正确的选择。就像 Stepanov 在他的《使用组件进行高效编程》A9 系列中所说的那样，我在读完《从数学到泛型编程》后正在学习这个系列。在前几节课中，他有一个关于 OOP 的五分钟离题，因为他正在使用 OOP。他说，听着，听着。你知道，他们说我曾公开表示我不喜欢 OOP。这可能是真的，也可能不是，但这并不意味着当它是完成工作的正确工具时，我不会使用它。所以是的，仅仅因为你是泛型编程的忠实粉丝，也就是 Stepanov 或你自己，并不意味着你不会使用其他范式或技术……
to generic programming. And like the first couple lectures, he has this little five minute digression on OOP because he's making use of OOP. And he's like, listen, listen. You know, they say I'm on record saying I don't like OOP. And that may or may not be true, but doesn't mean I'm not going to use it when it's the right tool for the job. And so yeah, it's just because you're a big fan of generic programming, AKA Stepanov or yourself, doesn't mean you're not going to use other paradigms or techniques
当它是正确的事情时，对吧？对，对。而且正确的事情有时只是你正在工作的代码库中的方式，因为改变太多了。这就是 Tony 的一大观点，对吧？正确的风格或正确的格式就是周围代码正在做的事情，
when it's the right thing to do, right? Right, right. And the right thing to do is sometimes just the way it is in the code base you're working in, because it's too much to change. That's what one of Tony's big things is, right? Is the right style or right formatting is whatever the surrounding code is doing,
因为任何其他方式看起来都会格格不入。对。所以是的，我的演讲是另一个关于声明式的。我称之为《声明式风格的演进》。回顾我 2018 年关于声明式风格的演讲。这是续集吗，官方续集？这算是一种续集吧，我想。我真的不知道。
because anything else is just going to look out of place. Right. So yeah, so my talk was another declarative one. I called it Declarative Style Evolved. Call back to my 2018 talk about declarative style. Is this a sequel, an official sequel or official sequel? It's a sequel of sorts, I suppose. I don't really know.
我谈论的是声明式结构。如果第一次演讲谈论的是单个函数调用、函数体和表达式层面的风格，那么这次演讲更多是谈论 API 层面的。在某种程度上是为声明式风格构建 API，但也认识到……好吧，其中一部分来自，或者说大部分来自我现在所做的工作，也就是嵌入式工作，非常繁重，IO，对吧？如果程序可以想象成一个天平，我们一边是数学，另一边是 IO，所有程序都做这两者中的一些，或者几乎所有……
I was talking about declarative structure. So if the first talk was talking about style at the level of individual function calls and function bodies and expressions, then this talk was more talking about the level of APIs. So structuring APIs for a declarative style somewhat, but also recognizing that, well, part of it came from, or most of it, I would say came from the work I do now, which is, you know, embedded work very heavily, IO, right? And if programs are sort of, you can imagine on a balance, we have maths on one side and IO on the other side, all programs do some of both, or almost all
程序都做这两者中的一些。大多数程序可能做的数学比 IO 多，但大多数嵌入式程序，比如我的工作，做的 IO 比数学多得多。这全都是关于在 IO 模块之间调度数据之类的事情。计算很少。总之，而且在嵌入式中，很多事情都处于全局 API 的层面。所以这也是我演讲的主题。我们有一个用于日志记录的全局 API。我们有另一个用于并发的全局 API，还有一个用于处理错误的，诸如此类。当你提到声明式 API 时，我脑海中浮现出的两件事是 Python 中的 sorted 与 sort 函数，一个是原地操作，
programs do some of both. Most programs do more maths than IO probably, but most programs on embedded, like my work, do way more IO than maths. It's all about marshalling data between I-O modules and things like that. There's very little calculation. Anyway, and also in embedded, a lot of things are just at the level of there is a global API. So that was a theme of my talk as well. We've got a global API for doing logging. We've got another global API for doing concurrency, another one for doing handling errors, that kind of thing. When you say declarative APIs, in my head, the two things that pop up are the sorted versus sort functions in Python, where one's in place
一个是异地操作，还有其他像流式 API，或者构建者模式，你不是有一堆原地操作，做这个，做那个，而是可以把一些东西串联起来，然后在底层，就像你说的，是一堆突变。这是正确的想法吗，还是你的演讲关注的是不同的东西？我想我的演讲是在那之上的层面，或者说是，你如何选择使用哪个 API？因为其中一个问题，一个反复出现的问题，特别是……
versus out of place, and other things like fluent APIs, or the builder pattern, where you're kind of, instead of having a bunch of in place, do this, do that, you can kind of chain some stuff together, and then under the hood, like you said, it's a bunch of mutation. Is that the right idea or is it your talk focusing on, on something different? I think my talk was sort of at the level above that, or it's like, how do you choose which API to use? Because one of the problems, one of the recurring problems with particularly
在嵌入式工作中，你如何测试它？对。所以你希望能够在平台上使用与桌面测试中相同的 API。对吧？但实现需要改变。对吧？因为你想要在 API 的层面进行测试，
with embedded work is you, how do you test it? Right. So you want to be able to use the same API on the platform as you do in desktop tests. Right? But the implementation needs to change. Right? Because you want to test at the level of the API
并尽可能多地向下推送平台特定的实现。这就是这次演讲所解决的问题。你知道，所以我可以在声明使用哪个 API 实现的层面进行声明。我可以尽可能地向下推送它，这样测试就可以尽可能多地使用相同的 API，甚至在尽可能低的层面使用相同的实现。有趣。
and push down as much platform-specific implementation as possible. And that's what this talk kind of addressed. You know, so I can declare at the level of which implementation to use for the API. And I can push that down as far as possible so that tests as far as much as possible can just use the same API and even the same implementation down to as far down as I can push it. Interesting.
所以这听起来确实和你第一次的演讲非常不同。这是一场非常不同的演讲。它涵盖了各种各样的事情。在准备演讲时，我得出的一个令人惊讶的结论是，我不认为测试……我认为测试应该是命令式的。事实上，演讲结束后，Kirk Shoop，我和他谈话，我想是在第二天左右，他说，他说，你知道，我想那可能是因为测试不会组合，我们不会组合测试。我在演讲中指出，测试应该足够简单，以至于你只需要说：安排（arrange）、行动（act）、断言（assert），对吧？那是你在测试中所做的经典三部曲。如果你只是有安排、行动、断言，那就是命令式的。没有理由走声明式编程路线来让它变得更简单。我想我在思考你所说的意思，因为当我想到我最近编写的单元测试时，最后肯定有一个语句和断言，但通常它是某种输入的构建，然后你执行行动，这在我的……
So this does sound like a very different talk than your first. It was a very different talk. It covered all kinds of things. One of the surprising sort of conclusions I reached in making the talk was that I don't think that tests, I think tests should be imperative. And actually after the talk Kirk,
情况下，很多时候，它是……好吧，它是声明式完成的吗？它只是，你知道，像 `auto const result = ...` 之类的输入。然后你有你的 `auto const expected`，然后你断言这些东西是相等的，或者你正在检查的任何属性。所以我想当你提到测试应该是命令式时，那是一个命令式测试的例子吗？如果是这样，它是最后的断言吗？或者我想，声明式测试和命令式测试之间有什么区别？你知道，我们不要纠结于试图定义什么是命令式与声明式。但我认为测试应该简短。
Kirk Shoop, I was talking to him, I think the day after or so and he said, he said, you know, I think that's probably because tests don't compose, we don't compose tests. And I made the point in the talk that tests should be simple enough that you just say, arrange, act, assert, right? That's the classic kind of trio of things you do in a test. And you just, if you just have arrange, act, assert, that's imperative. There's no reason to go down a declarative programming route to make that any simpler. I guess I'm trying to think what do you mean by because when I'm thinking of like the unit test that I have most recently written, definitely there's a statement and assertion at the end, but usually it's a construction of some input and then you are doing the act, which in my
它们应该足够短，以至于在显示器距离下，测试内容不会超过你的视觉范围。所以测试的长度应该像，你知道，少于 10 行。是的，我想到 10 行是一样的。测试不应该是什么，我们可以将其与我经常看到的测试进行对比，即使用模拟（mocking）框架的测试往往会变长，它们往往会混淆“安排”和“断言”，因为模拟框架总是做这种设置期望的事情。
case a lot of the times like it can be, well, is it declaratively done? It'll just be, you know, like autoconst result equals, et cetera, et cetera, of the input. And then you have your autoconst expected, and then you assert that those things are equal or whatever property you're checking. So I guess when you say tests should be imperative, is that an example of an imperative test? And if so, is it the it's the assertion at the end? Or I guess what's what's the difference between declarative and imperative testing? You know, let's not get hung up on trying to define what imperative versus declarative means. But I think tests ought to be short.
所以这混淆了关于测试的时间推理。你把“安排”和“断言”放在了同一个地方。然后最后你执行“行动”。我通常发现当使用模拟时，它并不能改善情况。我见过，你知道，也许有一种使用模拟的好方法。如果有的话，我在职业生涯中工作的团队里大多没见过。所以我得出的结论是，模拟只会把事情搞乱，也许在试图使它……我们可以争论它是声明式……
They ought to be short enough that you can just, the test takes up no more than your visual field of view at the distance of your monitor. So the length of a test ought to be like, you know, less than 10 lines. Yeah, I was thinking 10 lines is the same. And what tests should not be, we can contrast that with what tests I often see, which is tests that use mocking frameworks tend to get longer, they tend to confuse, arrange with assert, because mocking frameworks invariably do this thing where you set up expectations.
还是命令式。但总之，那种风格我不喜欢。是的，我的意思是，我支持这一点。我老实说从未使用过模拟框架。每当 AI 建议我使用模拟时，我都会说，不，我们在这里不需要那样做。那是不必要的。我过去常听一个 Android 播客，他们总是谈论……对于正在听的 Android 开发人员，我可能会说错，但类似于 Dagger 与 Juice，有所有这些用于测试的依赖注入和模拟框架。我记得……
And so it's confusing the sort of temporal reasoning about the test. You're putting the arrange and the assert in the same place. And then finally you're doing the act. I usually find that when mocks are used, it does not improve things. I've seen, you know, maybe there's a way to use mocks well. If there is, I mostly haven't seen it on teams I've worked in in my career. And so I've come to the conclusion that mocks just confuse things in perhaps trying to make, you know, we can argue whether it's declarative
听着听着就觉得，什么，为什么所有这些东西都是必要的？我想在某些情况下，如果你试图做一些 UI 测试，你必须设置一些状态等等，但我不知道，我想作为库开发人员，你很少需要模拟，如果有人告诉你你需要，我不知道，我会质疑这一点。我同意，在单元测试层面，我想要的是简单。事情要简单到我不需要去寻找一个框架来模拟 API。我只想在那个测试中测试我想要测试的那个函数。
or imperative. But anyway, that style, that style I don't like. Yeah, I mean, I can get behind that. I honestly have never used a mocking framework. And whenever AI recommends me using mocking, I'm like, no, we don't need to do that here. That's not necessary. And I used to listen to an Android podcast and they were always talking about, I'm going to get these wrong for the Android devs that are listening, but it's something like Dagger versus juice versus there's all these dependency injection and mocking frameworks for tests. And I remember
是的。是的。是的，我完全同意这一点。模拟框架也……这可能不适用于现在所有的模拟框架，但我认为对于大多数框架来说，它们绝对是为了经典的面向对象类层次结构、虚函数世界而生的。这会推动你，这有点像让尾巴摇狗，对吧？如果你的测试框架决定了你如何构建代码以便测试它，那么这对我来说似乎是本末倒置，这也是我不喜欢模拟框架的另一个原因。对。对。好的。是的，我绝对支持这一点。我不能一定说我见过所有的模拟框架……
listening to it just being like, what, why is all that stuff necessary I guess you in some cases it is if you're trying to do some like UI testing you have to set up some some state and whatnot but I don't know I guess as a library developer you very rarely have need for like mocking and if if someone's telling you that you do I don't know I would question that I agree and the level of unit tests what I want is for things to be simple. Things to be so simple that I don't need to reach for a framework to mock out APIs. I just want to test the one function I want to test in that test.
使用得不好或不是最优的，但那只是因为我避开了它们。没有在必须使用它们的团队或库中工作过。我们几乎总是只使用单元测试框架，并尝试编写简短的测试。总之，还有很多其他好的演讲。Braydon 做了一个演讲，Braydon Gnetsky，《Lambda All the Things》，这是一个非常有趣的演讲，
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I totally agree with that. Mocking frameworks also, this might not be true of all mocking frameworks now, but I think it's certainly still true of the majority that they absolutely live for the classical object oriented class hierarchy virtual function world. And that pushes you, that sort of makes the tail wag the dog, right? If your test framework is dictating how you structure your code so that you can test it, then that seems the wrong way around to me, which is another reason I don't like mocking frameworks. Right. Right. Okay. Yeah, I definitely can stand behind that. I can't necessarily say that I've seen all mocking frameworks
他采用了……你知道，我可以从 Lambda 制造一切吗？我可以从 Lambda 制造类型特征吗？我可以走这条路吗？这对 C++ Now 来说是一场非常好的演讲，因为它属于那种显然没人会在生产代码中那样做的演讲。但这是那种好玩的演讲，一种探索想法并将其推向荒谬结论的演讲，但……
used poorly or not optimally, but that's just because I have avoided them. Have not worked on a team or a library that has to make use of them. We almost always just use unit testing frameworks and try to write short tests. Anyway, so there were lots of other good talks. Brayden gave a talk, Brayden Gnetsky, Lambda All the Things, which was a very fun talk
我们沿途学到了东西，对吧？对。是的。在我看来，这非常符合 C++ Now 的精神，你知道，那种趣味性。是的。我的意思是，你过去也做过那样的演讲。《std accumulate 算法帝国》也做了类似的事情，对吧？什么，你以为那不是认真的？
where he took the idea of, you know, can I make everything from lambdas? Can I make type traits from lambdas? Can I go down this road? It was a very nice talk for C++ now, because it was one of these talks that, obviously, no one would do that in their production code. But it's the sort of talk that's a playful talk, a talk that explores an idea and takes it to even absurd conclusions, but
我想你在演讲中也这么说了。是的，再次强调，是的，那是在探索一个想法。我也倾向于在闪电演讲中经常这样做。你知道，展示一些奇怪的东西。而且你知道，你和我都是语言的粉丝。语言体现了计算范式。你知道，从某种意义上说，你知道，C++ 和 Java……
we learn things along the way, right? Right. Yes. That, in my view, is very much the spirit of C++ now, you know, the playfulness. Yeah. I mean, you've given talks like that in your past as well. The std accumulate algorithmic empire does kind of the same thing, right? What, you thought that was not serious?
和 Python 和 C#，它们其实都算是同一种语言。它们都源自 Algol，对吧？但像 Lisp 或 Smalltalk 或 Prolog 这样的语言则不同。它们在本质上是不同的。它们属于不同的家族，对吧？所以有时我想到语言时，我有一个我使用的术语，即“一切都是 X 语言”。这种语言是“一切都是 X 语言”吗？
I think you said as much in the talk. Yeah, again, yes, it was exploring an idea. I tend to do that a lot in lightning talks as well. You know, show some weird thing. And you know, you and I are both fans of languages in general. And the idea that languages embody computational paradigms. You know, so in a sense, you know, C++ and Java
你知道，C++ 不是，但 Scheme 是。一切都是 S 表达式。一切都是表达式，对吧？Lua 是。一切都是表，对吧？Prolog 一切都是子句，是那些真正严重依赖一个想法并看看能走多远的语言，在许多情况下，它们可以走得那么远，以至于成为一种完全的程序完备的编程范式。有一句名言，这就是我希望我更擅长……
and Python and C sharp, they're all really the same language ish. They're all descended from Algoll, right? But then something like Lisp or Smalltalk or Prologue, they are different. They are qualitatively different. They're different families, right? And so sometimes I think about languages like I have a sort of term that I use where it's everything is an X language. Is this language and everything is an X language?
我有一个朋友 Adam，他总是知道当下的格言或妙语，他总是脱口而出，但有一句名言或格言是，你知道，约束孕育创新之类的。这基本上就是你刚才谈到的，你知道，基本上就是你刚才谈到的。限制你被允许做的事情，然后你提出了一个看似不可能的创新解决方案，或者你永远不会向那个方向探索，因为你有其他路径可用，对吧？对，对。
You know, C++ is not, but like Scheme is. Everything's an S expression. Everything's an expression, right? Lua is. Everything's a table right prologue everything's a clause is that those kind of languages which really lean heavily onto one idea and just see how far they can take it and in many cases they can take it so far as to be to be a completely kind of program complete programming paradigm. There's some quote and this is where I wish I was better at I
在结束 C++ Now 回顾时，还有其他值得一提的演讲吗？还有很多其他好的演讲。Dietmar Kuhl 做了一个演讲叫《完成懒惰任务》，那是关于另一个关于发送者和接收者及其应用的演讲。我相信在那种情况下，它们对协程的应用是主题。是的。Zach 做了一个关于编写兼容 std 的……
had a friend Adam who always knew the aphorism or witticism for the moment he always just had him top of mind but there's some quote or aphorism that's you know, constraint breeds innovation or something like that. That is basically what you're talking about there that, you know, basically what you're talking about there. That limit what you're allowed to do and then you come up with a novel solution that would have seemed impossible or you never would have explored in that direction because you've got other paths available, right? Right, right.
视图的精彩演讲。然后我没能去参加 Steve Downey 的演讲，但我一定会确保在它发布后观看，《用热空气构建流》。哦，那是个吸引人的标题。使用发送者和接收者以 SICP 的风格构建流，你知道，我想是在第五讲左右，他们展示了，你知道，你认为的数据实际上在底层不一定是数据。它完全可以由函数组成。
Any other talks worth mentioning while we're winding down the C++ now recap. There were lots of other good talks. Dietmar Kuhl gave a talk called Getting the Lazy Task Done, and that was about another talk about senders and receivers and their application. In that case, their application to co-routines was the topic, I believe. Yes. And Zach gave a good talk about about writing stood compatible
对。所以我认为 Steve 的演讲走了类似的路线，虽然我没能亲自去现场看，因为它……你知道，那是演讲时段之一，有很多内容。对，对，对。我在想。是的，我记得那部分，他们有许多练习，你要计算下一个，你知道，数字。我不记得 Ramanujan 是否是其中之一。但是的，这是一个常见的……
views. And then a talk I didn't get to go to was Steve Downey's talk, but which I will make sure to catch as soon as it comes out, building streams out of hot air. Oh, that's a catchy title. Using senders and receivers to build streams in the style of SICP in the sense that, you know, I think it's about lecture five or so where they show that, you know, what you thought of as data really doesn't have to be data under the hood. It can just be made of functions.
是的，在学习函数式语言时，这是一个常见的练习，当你达到中级水平时，比如懒惰流，无限流。然后你可以从无限 iota 流开始。然后你当然可以，著名地，你可以做埃拉托斯特尼筛法来过滤。你只需要取流的头部，你用 2 开始流，你取头部并过滤掉那个，然后你取那个流的头部，过滤掉下一个，你最终过滤掉了所有素数的倍数。是的，这是一个非常好的实现，虽然不一定是复杂的，但它是……
Right. And so I think Steve's talk went down the similar vein, although I didn't get to see it in person because it was, you know, one of those talk slots where there was a lot. Right, right, right. I'm trying to think. Yes, I remember that part and they have a number of exercises where you are calculating the next, you know, number. I can't remember if Ramonajan was one of them. But yeah, it's a common.
你知道，如果你看不同的实现，技术上你应该从……是多少，2 或 3 开始，并做一些初步的效率处理，但是？你可以直接构建那个，而且非常非常快。好的，好吧，所有的演讲以及我们没提到的演讲。我相信 Ben 能提到的比这多。我相信我忘记了几个，但我会因为没提到而自责，但是。我们不能全部提到。实在太多了，
Yeah, in learning functional languages, that's a common exercise as you get toward the intermediate level of like the lazy stream, the infinite stream. And then you can start out with like an infinite iota stream. And then you can, of course, famously, you can do the Sivaritostinis to filter out. You just take the head of the stream, you start the stream with two, you take the head and you filter out that and they take the head of the stream, you start the stream with two, you take the head and you filter out that and they take the head of that stream, filter out the next, you end up filtering out all of the multiples of primes. Yes, a very nice implementation of what can be, well, not hairy necessarily, but it's,
但所有演讲的链接，就像我说的，都会在节目说明中。它们在接下来的一段时间里可能都会是所谓的“未公开”。但是的，如果你是在未来听这个节目，它们可能已经更新了。所以是的，C++ Now 告一段落。我不确定下一个是什么，
you know, if you look at the different implementations technically you're supposed to start it What is it two or three and and do some first pass for efficiency, but? You can just build that one up and very very quickly Okay, well all of the talks and the talks we didn't mention. I'm sure that there was more than Ben could mention. I'm sure I forgot several, but I'll kick myself for not mentioning, but. We can't mention them all though. There's way too many,
可能是 C++ on Sea。是的，我知道那个通常在六月底。然后 Cpp North 在七月。是的。然后我想那会带我们到 CppCon。可能还有，我知道其实有，我想它可能已经发生了。有一个虚拟的 C++……
but links to all of them, like I said, will be in the show notes. They probably will all be quote unquote, unlinked for the next period of time. But yeah, if you're listening to this in the future, they probably will be updated. So yeah, C++ now in the books. I'm not sure what's the next,
我正想说 C++ Under the Sea 也在其中，对吧？那是去年十月。我猜，我其实知道，我想我知道它大约在同一时间。所以我认为它在十月的某个时候。而且是的，还有很多其他的。我的意思是，我知道 Meeting C++ 在十一月，还有 Code Dive。Pure Virtual C++，我想你在刚才想说那个。
might be C++ on C. Yeah, I know that one's at the, typically it's at the tail end of June. And then Cpp North is in July. Yep. And then I think that brings us to CPPCon. There might be, I know actually there was, I think it might have already taken place. There was a virtual C++.
那个为期一天的微软在线会议，是的，我相信它发生在 C++ Now 的那一周。我想是 4 月 30 日。哦，那时间安排得真糟糕。去年也是一样。哦，去年也是吗？是的，2024 年。是的，我不得不录制我的演讲。
I was going to say C++ Under the Sea is somewhere in there as well, right? That one was October last year. And my guess, I actually know, I think I know it's the same, roughly the same time. So I think it's in October sometime. And yeah, there's a bunch of other ones. I mean, I know meeting C++ is in November as well as Code Dive. Pure Virtual C++, which I think you were about to say before.
Side Brand 联系了我，他们说，你想在 Pure Virtual C++ 上做个演讲吗？因为 Cy，我想他们发起了这个会议，或者他们肯定是推动举办的驱动力。所以是的，而且再次强调，它正好在 C++ Now 期间。所以我提前录制了我的演讲并发送了过去。所以当时我在参加一个会议，同时也能参加另一个，我想。你的一个副本在另一个会议上演讲，对于“副本”这个词的某种定义而言。
The one day Microsoft online conference that, yeah, that happened during the week of C++ now, I believe it was I think it was April 30. Oh, that's a bad sport timing. It was the same last year. Oh, was it last year? Yeah, 2024. Yes, I had to record my talk.
是的，我想我没看今年任何的演讲。但是的，我们会在节目说明中放上链接。我们生活在其中。这是 C++ 最好的部分之一，我们……不仅以讲座的形式，还有播客、博客文章，拥有极其丰富的内容，这在所有社区中是无法比拟的。作为一个喜欢尽可能多地摄取这类内容的人。是的，能观看这些内容真是太棒了。好的。我的意思是，我们也许应该给 C++ Now 2025 回顾画上句号，并过渡到……那是……
Side brand reached out to me and they said, would you like to give a talk at Pure Virtual C++? Because Cy, I think they originated the conference or they were certainly a driving force for putting it on. And yeah, so, and again, it fell during C++ now. So I recorded my talk ahead of time and sent it off. So then I was at one conference, able to attend another, I guess. A copy of you was speaking at another conference for some definition of the word copy.
第 234 期？请务必查看播客应用或 adspthepodcast.com 上的节目说明，获取今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号派。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Yeah, I don't think I saw any of the talks from this year. but yeah, we'll link in the shout-outs. There's tons we live in. That's one of the best parts about C++ is that we, there's a cornucopia of content in the form not just of lectures, but podcasts, blog posts, which is, can't be said of all communities. And as someone who likes to ingest as much of that kind of stuff as possible. Yeah, it's great to be able to watch this stuff. All right. I mean, we should maybe put a bow on the C++ Now 2025 recap and transition that was what
是的，我想我没看今年的任何讲座。不过，我们会把相关链接放在致谢部分。我们生活在海量内容中。C++ 最棒的地方之一就是它拥有极其丰富的内容，不仅有讲座，还有播客和博客文章，这一点并非所有社区都能做到。作为一个喜欢尽可能多地吸收这类内容的人，能观看这些内容真是太好了。好吧，我想我们应该为 C++ Now 2025 的回顾画上句号，并过渡到这是第几期节目来着？
episode 234? Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
第 234 期？请务必在您的播客应用中或访问 adspthepodcast.com 查看本期节目的展示说明，获取我们今天提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听，希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。我是反大括号派。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。